MALE SPEAKER: So
welcome, everybody.
It's good to welcome
everybody here.
It's nice to also welcome
Craig Redmond from Mercy Corps.
Craig is the Mercy Corps Senior
Vice President of Programs.
And for those of you, probably
mostly on VC, who don't know,
Mercy Corps is a
global organization
that helps people get
back on their feet
and survive, basically, in the
aftermath of natural disasters,
and in the wake of
economic crises,
or when conflict erupts--
basically any time when there
is an acute and/or
chronic challenge to peace
and stability and to progress.
And their goal in
those times is to try
to connect people in need
with resources and expertise
to try to realize fundamental
and transformative change
in societies.
And it's a very, very
worthy goal that, I think,
is something that resonates
deeply with folks at Google
as evidenced by the
fact that we actually
have a long history, a long and
good history, with Mercy Corps.
Mercy Corps has, I should
say, 4,000 members.
They live and work in
more than 40 countries.
And they face some of the
world's most difficult
challenges, as you
will see today.
But in terms of our history,
Google's history with Mercy
Corps, we have worked
closely with them
on a wide range of humanitarian
issues over the years.
I think Nepal is a
great example of that.
For folks who don't
know, we collectively
generated about $1.1 million
of donations, grants,
et cetera for Mercy Corps in the
context of the Nepal disaster.
And that was a combination
of Google.org giving,
a combination of Googlers
donating trips, credits,
and actual direct giving through
our GooglersGive for Disaster
Relief program, which
is company matched.
And all of that meaningfully
aggregated to a good number
of $1.1 million plus.
And more than 1,900
Googlers participated
in that, which is both really
exciting to see but it also
is a real opportunity.
Because by the way, we've
got about 60,000 employees.
So we could do a lot more.
And maybe this talk will inspire
folks so that the next time we
have an opportunity
to work with you guys,
that number doubles,
or triples, or even
grows by a much bigger number.
Mercy Corps also helped us
pioneer a new program, which
is-- this is a mouthful--
it's the GooglersGive Disaster
Corps, otherwise
known as the GDC.
It's a neat idea.
The idea, really, is to match
disaster relief organizations
who have a specific need
in terms of expertise
or some kind of technical
need with Googlers
who have a desire and
an inclination to give.
The name for this is
"philanthropic human capital
investment program
in disaster relief."
I don't know what-- I don't
know who came up with that name.
But I think that, more than
the money that provides,
that's an incredible
opportunity, both for you guys
but also for Googlers.
And I would really like to
promote this to all the folks
who are watching, because I
think, really, it's not just
about giving money, but
it's about giving expertise
and help in times of need.
17 Googlers participated in the
Nepal program through, I think,
five NGOs.
I think Mercy Corps
was one of them,
and hosted Googlers for a
number of weeks in Nepal.
And you will hear from some
of those Googlers today.
Let me give you a
little bit about Craig.
Craig Redmond has worked in
international development
and humanitarian response
for over 22 years.
15 of those years have been
with Mercy Corps leading
regional and country
operations in the Caucasus,
the Horn of Africa, South
Asia, and Southeast Asia.
And in his current
role, he leads
Mercy Corps' global
programs, including
humanitarian response, program
development, and operations
around the world.
I think it's fair to say
that Craig has played
a major role in
Mercy Corps' approach
to creating real, transformative
change in times of great need.
And I think we will hear
about how they combine
big ideas and bold action
with an appreciation
of local sensibility
to really bring
about change in times of need.
And it's an inspiring story,
so I should stop talking.
And I should actually
let you come up, Craig,
and we should start
to hear from you.
CRAIG REDMOND: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Craig.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG REDMOND: Thank you, Matt.
It's great to be here.
It's really a pleasure to
be here with all of you
to talk about-- I want to
talk to you about Nepal.
Where's the clicker?
MALE SPEAKER: Just point at me.
I got you.
CRAIG REDMOND: You got me.
OK.
This is Google after all.
I just point at somebody
and something-- fantastic.
Yeah, I want to talk
to you about Nepal.
And obviously, I'm
going to also talk
about the events that happened
in the spring, this spring.
But before we do that,
I want to tell you
what Nepal is really about.
Go ahead.
This is Nepal.
You know, any time,
unfortunately,
in places where we work,
there is a disaster,
or something terrible
has happened,
or there's a conflict
of some kind--
but really, there's a
reality of the place.
Like Nepal, this is a
fantastic, even magical place.
You know, I've been
there many times.
I started going
there in the 90s.
I'm a climber.
In fact, I climbed
this peak right here.
This is Ama Dablam.
You can see this beautiful
village down here.
And this is Everest,
right there.
This, for me, captures,
Nepal is a fantastic place,
beautiful place.
The people you
meet there who are
going there to visit go there
and talk about trekking.
And then they start
immediately talking about it
like some sort of
spiritual pilgrimage.
It's really a wonderful place.
Let's go to the next one.
This is a place called Tenboche.
It's a Tibetan monastery
not far from where
the other picture was taken.
So you can see, it's just
a rich, beautiful place
full of incredibly
resilient people.
And let's go to the next one.
And of course, on
the 20th of April,
there was a terrible earthquake.
And you here at Google also know
about that and you feel that.
You lost one of your own.
Dan Fredinburg died in
that in an avalanche.
So this is also-- you
guys feel this very much.
And so as I talk
through this, we'll
hold him and his
family in our hearts.
It's a terrible loss.
Terrible.
8,000 lives, in
excess of 8,000 lives,
were lost in just a few
minutes in that earthquake.
7.8 on the Richter scale.
Interestingly, Nepal
expected this to happen.
Of course, the
country sits right
on the two plates, the Indian
plate and the Eurasian Plate,
where they collide.
That's the Himalayas.
That's why the
Himalayas are there.
Let's go to the next one.
And because the
earthquake happened there,
it meant that communities,
local communities,
had to burst into
action very quickly.
In fact, the lives
that were saved there
in those early minutes
after the earthquake
were all local communities
who pulled their families
and pulled community members
out of that terrible storm.
And as I said, it was expected.
But in places all
over the world,
even though you know something
like this is likely to happen,
you're really never quite ready.
And this is one of those cases.
It was just a terrible,
terrible situation.
The next slide.
This is a village that I
visited in the weeks just
after the earthquake.
This is in Sindhupalchowk, which
is northeast from Kathmandu.
And above there is Langtang,
one of my favorite places
in the world.
It borders Tibet,
really beautiful place.
This village was
one of the places
where we visited
where, actually, we
did some of our early work.
And in this place-- you can't
really tell from this picture,
but you can see general
destruction-- about 2/3
of the houses were
destroyed there.
And in the next slide, you'll
see a picture of this house.
This was really common
after the earthquake.
You will walk along a street
and the houses will look normal.
And then you peek
around the side
and the whole side
of the house is gone.
So in fact, in another
village I was in,
something like
out of 100 houses,
only eight were left standing.
So really extreme devastation
throughout that whole part
of the country.
In some of the villages we
visited, if you can imagine,
a house like this--
of course, this
is uninhabitable-- somebody
has to pull it down.
We saw, in a few
places, where young men
were climbing on top of
the roofs of these houses
and starting to tear
them down brick by brick.
Not what you want to do.
But people just need to
get on with their lives.
Next slide.
This is a guy called
[? Mishual. ?]
We met him in one of the
villages where we worked.
He told us a story of being,
actually, up on a ladder
fixing one of the lights
in the village when
the earthquake happened.
And of course, he knew
immediately how bad it was.
He saw houses around him
starting to collapse.
Ran down, ran home, and
found his house collapsed.
And his wife and his son there,
in the picture, were inside.
And he was able to dig them
out and save their lives.
Really common story
where people talk
about what they had to
do to pull family members
and community members
out of the earthquake.
In that same village,
I was walking along
and I saw this woman.
She was standing
next to a rubble,
a big pile of rubble bricks
and pieces of splintered wood.
And she had a stick and
she was just poking at it
and turning over bricks.
And she had just experienced
such complete loss
that it was all that
she could imagine to do.
A very, very sad story there.
Next slide.
This is Bhaktapur,
a World Heritage
site built in the 15th century.
Incredible place.
Just a beautiful place.
This, in fact, is
my climbing partner,
Josh Duwal right here--
Mercy Corps guy also--
and his beautiful family.
And that was two years ago.
And we were there.
And the next slide
shows it two weeks
after the earthquake
when I visited there.
You can see, from that slide
as well, this incredible place
with so much rich culture and
everything largely destroyed,
very much of it destroyed.
And some of the buildings that
are still standing, in fact,
are leaning and are
going to have to be
pushed over-- a real tragedy.
Next slide.
So just as this horrible
tragedy happens,
it also creates an
opportunity for innovation.
It creates an opportunity
for these communities
to emerge in a way that they
never thought possible before.
And in fact, this is the
Google story as well.
You guys were there.
As Matt was saying, you
guys were there with us.
We had this incredible
support from the employees
at Google, which was wonderful,
and the disaster corps
team that was there with us.
It was fantastic.
So this is your story as well.
And I want to say a
few things about what
that recovery looked like.
In the minutes after,
in the hours after,
in the days
immediately following
one of these disasters,
one of the first things
you have to think about is
those absolute immediate needs
families and
communities will have.
And they're always the
same thing-- basically,
their shelter, their water,
their food, their sanitation.
What we have to do is find ways
to deliver those things as fast
as possible so that
people can survive
those very difficult
days following
an earthquake, or a tsunami, or
a cyclone, or whatever it is.
So like other NGOs, Mercy
Corps burst into action.
You can see, this is us putting
together emergency kits.
You've got your big
water buckets here.
You've got jerrycans,
blankets, towels, soap,
some sort of water
dispenser, the things
that people will
need just to survive.
And we did this in
an interesting way.
Right after the
earthquake, of course,
people were just
scrambling to find
whatever goods they could find.
We sent 10 team members
in all directions
to procure as much as we
could so that we could
go and distribute these things.
Over the weeks after
the earthquake,
we distributed about
115,000 of these kits
in the earthquake-affected
areas north of Kathmandu.
Next slide.
And in fact, these are
boxers full of the same kits.
And you can see that we
trucked them up, in some cases,
as far as we could,
unloaded them.
And then community members
came down to meet us.
And so we did
distributions that way.
Nepal, of course,
road system is,
the further into the
mountains you go,
the worse it gets
until, finally, there
are no more roads.
And you've got to go by foot.
And some of the things we
brought in by helicopter.
Others we had-- the next slide
shows how they got there.
So then, community
members come down.
You can see this
woman with a tumpline.
This is the traditional
way of carrying goods.
And by the way, these people
are incredibly powerful.
The amount of weight they
can carry on their backs
is just unbelievable.
So they would come down.
And they would
load up those goods
and carry them back and
either redistribute back
in their villages or-- that's
for a number of families
or whatever it is.
So that's how it's done.
And that's how it's done
in a place like Nepal.
And interestingly,
that's how it's
done in so many countries
around the world.
Immediately, when
you look at that,
you think, OK, it
has to be done.
There's a critical
need for those goods
to get into the hands of
people who need them most.
But talk about a system
that's ripe for disruption.
Something about it, something
about watching a distribution
just makes you think this
doesn't feel right somehow.
Surely, there's a better
way that this can be done.
And there is.
I'm not saying you
shouldn't do distributions.
You should when it's necessary.
And in those early days,
it's the right thing to do.
But what we really like
to do at Mercy Corps
is-- the next slide-- cash.
We believe that there's nothing
more important than getting
cash, capital, into the hands
of people who have suffered
the most so that they can make
way for their own recovery,
so they can buy the things
that they need themselves.
That's a critically
important step.
Not easy to do.
The use of path is critical
for three main reasons
post-emergency.
Number one, it takes the
emphasis away from us,
or whoever's doing
the distribution
or the procurement, and gives
it back to the people who
have suffered most so that they
are making their own decisions
around their recovery.
Maybe these women
here want to spend--
you can see they're in
a shop there-- maybe
they want to buy some
goods right there.
They buy what they need
and it's up to them.
Maybe they want to save that
money and spend it later.
Maybe they want to give
it to a community member
or maybe they want to give
it to a family member.
That's entirely up to them.
But the point is it puts
the power in their hands
and not in our hands,
which is the point.
Second, what it
does immediately is
it stimulates the local economy.
Of course they go to
their trusted shopkeeper
that they've always worked
with for years and years.
And they put that
money right back
into their local economy rather
than a procurement that's
happening elsewhere,
and brought in,
and potentially
disrupting those markets.
That's the last
thing we want to do.
We want to stimulate markets and
make sure those things recover
as quickly as possible.
And third, it creates portals
for financial inclusion.
What I mean by that is
it creates opportunities
so that more kinds
of formal banking
can be done with those
people after some time.
Some of the mobile
banking work that we
do, as a result of
that, it creates
an opportunity for people to
establish savings accounts,
for them to open lines of
credit so that they have,
post-emergency, much better
access to financial services,
which is really important.
So the whole point here is
trying to use innovation
in a way that creates
a situation that
was better than it was before
the emergency happened.
So how do you do it?
In Nepal, it was interesting,
because a few things happened.
Number one, the
earthquake disrupted
the microfinance system.
There's a pretty well-developed
microfinance system
pretty far into the mountains.
That collapsed.
So money was not flowing at all.
The commercial banking
system also collapsed.
So that wasn't
working at all either.
So at Mercy Corps, we
thought, how can we do this.
What can we do to make sure
that we can get capital
into the hands of people
as quickly as possible?
And what we did was, the
team came up with this idea,
let's use local shopkeepers
as the cashout point.
Let's find a way to get
the cash into the hands
of the shopkeepers
people always use
and have them
distribute the cash,
thereby using a system
that they already trust
and stimulating the economy.
And that's what we did.
And we basically
built on a system
that we tried in the Philippines
after Haiyan-- the big storm
there, the typhoon
there-- and built on that
and riffed on it a little bit.
And we came up with this system.
And as a result, we reached some
25,000 households in that way.
That hadn't been done before.
The idea of using cash to
stimulate local economies
is now a really critically
important strategic point
for Mercy Corps in
every emergency we do.
We ask ourselves,
number one, what can
we do to stimulate the markets.
What can we do to make sure that
we don't disrupt the markets?
And how can we get
cash into their hands?
And in this case,
that was the solution.
Next slide.
It's a little bit--
I love this picture.
That guy looks pretty happy
to have those rupees in hand.
It's a little bit in
keeping with this ethos
that we talk about
in Mercy Corps,
community led, market driven.
How can we do both
things at once,
let the community
lead their recovery
and stimulate markets,
and tie what we're doing
into the marketplace as well?
Next slide.
So in those areas,
post-earthquake,
Mercy Corps' strategy
for a long-term recovery
has three pieces to it.
Number one, it has a disaster
risk reduction part to it.
You can see from
this slope here,
these communities-- you can see
how this land is sloughing off
here-- these communities need
to think very hard about,
where are the future shocks and
stresses going to come from,
because they will come.
So helping those
communities think out
what's going to happen
the next time there's
an earthquake, what's going
to happen when there is,
potentially, a landslide, when
the rains come, and so forth,
and those hillsides slough
off-- so disaster risk reduction
is really important.
Second, keep pushing
the frontiers
on the financial inclusion.
How can we make sure more
people have access to capital?
In the Himalayas,
the higher you go
in altitude, of course, the
higher the cost per transaction
means that the lesser
number of people
have access to
financial services.
In the lowlands,
everybody has access.
High in the mountains like these
places, very few people do.
How can we push that
frontier and get
more people connected
to financial services
is what we're trying to do.
Interestingly, and I
started with talking
about how resilient Nepal
is, Nepal is going to be OK.
It's an incredible place,
as I said, resilient people.
The recovery is well in place.
I'm not saying
everything is rosy.
It's not.
They're having serious problems
with the constitution now,
and there have been
riots over fuel,
and many things
are going on there.
But overall, Nepal
is going to be OK.
It's going to come
out of this one.
Other parts of the
world are just not OK.
And I know we've all
read these numbers,
but globally, right now, over
60 million people are displaced,
the biggest number of people
displaced since World War II.
That's a huge number.
Mercy Corps is working--
and this picture is actually
taken in Zaatari camp.
About 180,000 people
live in this camp.
It's inside Jordan, just
over the border from Syria.
We're serving about 4 million
people in and around Syria.
And in fact, in Zaatari camp,
we put in the big water system
here.
It was a huge undertaking.
But that's a piece of work
that we did right there
in Zaatari camp.
When we think about the
pressures facing the world
right now, such as Zaatari
camp, such as the refugees who
are leaving Syria and that
whole part of the world,
it's going to take a
huge amount of work.
This is the picture that
our team took in Greece
as some refugees
arrived from Turkey,
crossed the Mediterranean.
And we're seeing these
numbers escalate.
We surpassed 700,000
this year so far.
And everybody expects
that those numbers
are going to go way
beyond that next year.
Double, triple, who
knows what it will be?
It'll be huge.
Next slide.
This is a picture of
our guide, [? Mugher, ?]
who is there talking to
some refugees about routes,
and how to get to safe places,
and how to get information
Mercy Corps works-- not only do
we work in each of the places
where refugees are
coming from currently,
but we're also working
in Turkey, and Greece,
and in the Balkans, and
in all the places where
refugees are passing through.
We have great people on
the ground, that's true.
But the fact is that
we're never going
to be able to meet this need.
We have a huge need
for three basic things
as we look at a
crisis as complex
as the Mediterranean
refugee crisis.
Number one, we have
to keep innovating.
For sure, we know
that if there were
magic solutions to these things,
everyone would be using them.
There just aren't.
And in the emergency
response space,
there seems to be a
dearth of innovations
that are happening regularly.
We have to keep
pushing on this front.
The use of cash, things
like that, other ways
to get cash into people's
hands are critically important.
So that innovation piece is
really, really important.
Number two, we have to partner
with organizations like Google.
This is how we're
going to find--
this is how we're going to
combine things that we never
thought of to find solutions.
It was such a
tremendous pleasure
for our team to work with
all of you from Google.
Because you guys think in
ways that we don't think.
And I imagine that we think
in ways that you don't think.
We love the idea of combining
these things in fresh ways.
If we don't find ways to
work together at scale,
I think some of these things
are going to get out of hand
and we won't be
able to manage them.
And the last slide.
From the Mercy Corps
side, I can say
I'm talking to our team in
Nepal and talking to our team
elsewhere too.
We are really proud of
the work that we're doing.
We're really proud of the
partnerships like the one
we have with Google.
I think we should challenge
ourselves and say,
where else can we do this.
What are some other huge,
complicated challenges
that we can take on
and solve together?
I'd like to ask these guys to
come up and say a few words
about your experience.
So Scott and Aswan--
Aswan, if you
can come up and say a few
things about your experience
when you were there.
And then after that, we
can have a conversation.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Well
thanks, Craig.
Appreciate the partnership
with Mercy Corps.
And as one of the
17 Googlers going
to Nepal to work with your
organization among others,
feel very privileged
for the opportunity.
For me, I hadn't even yet
crossed the one year mark
of my tenure here at Google.
But when I heard about
the earthquake in Nepal,
it was very both
personally touching for me
and also surreal.
About a year prior,
I had been in Nepal,
among other places
in the Himalayas,
for about seven years
working primarily
on energy and rural
community development.
And so when this
happened, I wondered,
well, was there something
now, as a Googler,
that I might be able
to do and to help with.
So upon hearing about
the application,
and applying, and
about a week later,
finding myself on a plane
en route to Kathmandu,
stepping off the
plane, it almost
looked like nothing
had changed in the year
that I had been away.
But as soon as we ventured out
into other parts of Kathmandu,
and especially
into Sindhupalchok
in the more rural areas
that were affected
by the earthquake,
we could very easily
see that lives were changed
just within a matter of minutes.
And so initially,
I thought, perhaps
my work in the Himalayas, with
communities like those that
were affected prior or in some
of the earthquakes, the two
earthquakes, that had
happened in China years
prior might come in handy.
But to my surprise,
a lot of the work
that I have been doing in
the past year here at Google
has been working
with data providers,
working with advertisers,
and together,
trying to onboard their data
for shopping and advertising
products that we have here.
Didn't think that that
would come in handy.
Boy, was I surprised.
So Craig was talking about
the new innovative program
around cash that
they'd been running.
And one of the challenges
that they had identified
was, how do we
monitor and evaluate
that program to see
that it's effective,
with the outputs
and outcomes are.
And all of a sudden, things
started coming into focus.
And I saw, actually,
this is like some
of the challenges we run up
against with our advertisers
here at Google.
How do we onboard the data and
make a clean data pipeline?
And so myself as well as
seven other colleagues
began, in our first week,
understanding more about, what
was the context, what was
the meat in the problem,
and then trying to
come up with a solution
to work with Mercy Corps in
developing a way to streamline
that data pipeline.
And so I never would have
expected these two worlds,
my past life as well as,
now, my world here at Google,
to come into play.
So that's about the
beginning of what has now
turned into, I think,
a bigger adventure of,
what else can we
do here at Google.
And I think that this was
a really amazing experience
to show that there are
a lot of opportunities,
especially collaborating with
very innovative organizations
like Mercy Corps.
And I have to say
that, on the ground,
it was very impressive to
see the work that they've
been doing, and not only the
very incredible programmatic
work that they've done.
But I think, also, what
lies at the heart of this
are the great people that
they have on the ground.
And I think, for
each of us, it was
a very impressive experience.
So I wanted to say a few things
and turn the rest of the time
over to Aswan to
share his experiences.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Scott.
Thank you, Craig.
So similar to the experiences
that my colleagues have already
shared, Nepal, I had
visited there before.
And it was a country that
struck me as pristine
but also very culturally rich.
And so going and visiting
back and seeing, hey,
there's obviously
something-- there's
a fabric-- that's
been shook here,
but not understanding
the extent of it
as soon as I had walked off into
the airport where the hustle
and bustle was, it was humbling,
and at the same time, scary.
The only thing that I took away
in my first experience to Nepal
was nature.
In my second
experience to Nepal,
which was the trip with Mercy
Corps was remarkably different.
So first of all, myself
and my colleagues,
there were some folks that
were focused on data pipeline
and how to do better reporting,
which Scott mentioned.
There was teams
focused on, how do
I elevate the visibility of
what's being done with funds.
There were teams that were
tutoring local startups on how
to do better front end
design, which is something
that innovative tech
companies can help to teach.
And then there's
also organizations
that were-- there were
teams that were focused on,
how do we better fundraise.
How do we better
use donor funds?
So there was obviously a
plethora of opportunity there.
And this was actually a
remarkably competitive
experience to get into
this particular initiative
that Google was
running, hopefully
will be replicated again.
Now in terms of the personal
impact to me-- and I mentioned,
first time, I'd only taken away
some of the pristine wilderness
and the Himalayan
tracks and visiting
some of the cultural temples.
I think the second trip was
remarkably different for me.
One of the stories that I
remember is a colleague of mine
had generated a number
of handwritten letters
from the United States in order
to actually deliver to children
like a pen pal system.
And one of the older
girls, after reading
the letters with tears
streaming down her face,
approached a group of us,
and one person in particular,
and said, I want to
thank you for being here.
And next time, if you ever have
an earthquake in your country,
I would be happy to
come out and help you.
Now I want to contextualize
the backdrop of a statement
like this, a girl who
has lost family members,
has been displaced
from her home,
and whose family is
undergoing really hard times.
And what I want to
categorize there is,
there is no better indicator
of the cultural fabric
of a society than when the
environment around them
is strained.
And for me to see
something like that,
and for me to actually
be able to inculcate
some of the learnings
from a very, very
small seven-year-old girl
was a remarkable experience.
So what I would
say to everybody,
the Googler on the livestream,
the people in the room,
is that Google donated money.
And people should
obviously donate money.
But you should invest your time.
And the reason I don't
say that I donated
my time or the Googlers
donated their time
is because we actually
got far more from it
than what we put in.
So a donation is something
that, you set it, you forget it,
you let it go.
But an investment is something
that you reap abundant rewards
from.
And so for me, that
categorizes and epitomizes
some of the experiences
that myself, my colleagues,
and my Mercy Corps
working comrades
experienced in our Nepal trip.
So with that said, I'll hand
it back to the presenters.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG REDMOND: I think we
wanted to open up to questions.
But before we do that,
we have a wee gift.
So this is for the
Google disaster corps.
This is a--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Would
you mind [INAUDIBLE]?
CRAIG REDMOND: This is a
thangka, a traditional art
form, of course, that Tibetan
Buddhists use in Nepal.
And so on behalf of the Mercy
Corps team, particularly
the Nepal team,
and to all of you
that helped us out so incredibly
here at Google, it's an honor.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG REDMOND: So if
there are any questions,
you guys want to join me?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, sure.
So the question
was, for the folks
who are involved
in the effort, how
did we engage with the
experience of being in Nepal
and also engage
with the community.
And also, how did the
community see our involvement?
I'll answer this
question in two ways.
So the first way is that our
experiences not only focused
on some of the core work we
were doing with Mercy Corps,
but also were involved-- we
were involved with folks who
were part of startups
in the local community
and that wanted and saw
Google as an opportunity
for mentorship to
learn best practices.
And we conducted some of these
activities on the weekends
as we weren't working
part of our core group.
So that was the way
in which we connected
with the tech community.
We helped to-- I
want to say inspire.
I hope they were inspired.
I was actually more so
inspired by their dedication
and wanting to be there,
wanting to stay home,
wanting to stay close
to their family,
wanting to use
technology to rebuild.
The second piece is that I think
it's very easy, when you relate
to a community and you
come from a company
like Google, to think about
everything in terms of numbers.
And what the numbers obfuscate
is the human experience
that goes behind it.
And so I think that we could
have done this "project"--
we could have done it displaced.
We could have done
it from a conference
room across the hall.
But it wouldn't have had the
local sensibilities embedded
in it.
It wouldn't have
driven the team members
to be nearly as
passionate, because it
was an academic exercise.
And the folks who were on the
ground and delivering this
wouldn't have had the
opportunity to work with us
and also feed off of
some of the energy
that we were bringing from that.
So I feel like that was a
bit of a cycle that we were
able to create, both working
off the Mercy Corps folks
and the Googlers.
CRAIG REDMOND: I have
a question, actually,
for you guys.
What's something
that you absolutely
did not expect
when you got there
in terms of what an emergency
response was going to be like?
MALE SPEAKER: I did not
expect that the recovery
phase would have shifted to
more of the ongoing needs.
Everything that I had
seen in the news, which
lasted for probably the first
two weeks after the earthquake,
demonstrated a lot of
very urgent basic needs.
But I didn't understand
the complexity
that organizations
like Mercy Corps
were trying to
solve amidst working
with other humanitarian
and aid organizations,
working with the
governments, and, actually,
the importance and
the potential role
that technology can play in
really providing leverage,
transparency, clarity, and
overall organization to help
make sure that the programs are
as effective as they could be.
MALE SPEAKER: What
I didn't expect
is the focus on making
things stronger.
And I think that
was actually one
of the titles of this
entire presentation.
So what I imagined
was that we were
going to try to get everybody
back to steady state
and then we're going to leave.
And what I realized is
that the NGOs working there
were using the-- they were both
addressing the immediate needs
and capitalizing
on the opportunity
to do something
transformative, change
the way the economy works to
start inspiring people to pick
up businesses, to get
industry kickstarted,
to start the conversation
around health care.
So they were using what was
an untimely, and disastrous,
and very unfortunate event
as a platform for growth
and for a better,
healthier society.
CRAIG REDMOND: That's
a great observation.
If you look at it from a
resilience perspective--
we talk about a
resilience lens there--
the idea is communities
able to absorb, and adapt,
and transform beyond
where they were before.
I think it's exactly
the right word for that.
MALE SPEAKER: And I remember,
one of the common messages
that we heard almost
everyone we ran into say was,
go home, tell
everyone, visit Nepal.
CRAIG REDMOND: Right.
Exactly.
That's the time to go.
That's when they need it most.
AUDIENCE: Were there any
insights or surprises
that you had about how
technology, and the internet,
and connectivity were
relevant in a place like Nepal
after a disaster?
Anything that you would keep
in mind thinking forward
to another situation
where the assets of Google
and the internet could be used?
MALE SPEAKER: So I guess I'll
start off answering this one.
I think that there's
been a macro trend that
has changed how the world
interacts with data.
And what I mean by that
is that previously,
everybody did as much as
they could possibly do.
And it was, let me try to
do everything that I can
with what little I have.
Now I feel like folks are making
very informed choices about,
how do I maximize
the productivity
of every single
dollar that I spend
similar to a way in which, I
would say, a business is run,
but not with the business
objective of, let me maximize
profit, but how do I
maximize human welfare.
And to me, there is
no better intersection
of what Google is trying to do
around creating transparency,
helping data shape
choices that people make,
and the type of work that
Mercy Corps and NGOs are trying
to do, which is, we're
out of the ground,
but we need help zooming
out and making informed
choices about how we
allocate our resources
or who we try to go help first.
AUDIENCE: You're
talking about innovation
being important to Mercy Corps.
Can you tell a
little bit about-- I
know you recently had your
first head of innovation
a couple years ago.
Can you just tell a
little bit about why
you started that,
what came of it,
what's going on now that's
different from before you had
actually named that and
made that a role and a group
at your organization?
CRAIG REDMOND: Yeah,
great question.
Mercy Corps has, from
the beginning-- well,
not from the beginning, but
from the '80s-- actually
been talking about
social entrepreneurship
as a critical part of our DNA.
And I think, from
that emphasis to being
entrepreneurial wherever we
are, that we parlayed that
into more of a conversation
around innovation.
As I said in the presentation,
one of the issues
is that it feels
like, in our space,
there are so many
organizations--
and not to say anything
bad about anybody--
but that have been doing the
same thing over and over again
for a long time.
And there isn't enough
push for innovation,
to bring innovation
into our space
to solve these big problems.
So we just have felt,
as an organization,
that it's critical
that we push that.
Otherwise, the
same old problems,
the intractable issues that
we can't break friction on,
are just going to persist.
So innovation is a major driver
for us and has been forever.
Some years ago, we formed
a social ventures team,
a social innovations
team whose job
it is to be out in the field
and to identify initiatives
or concepts that come up
and help the field team grab
those things and
develop them further
into something, whether it be a
venture, a standalone venture,
or just a really cool project
that has innovation driving it.
Then we brought in a
chief innovations officer
to help us further that thing.
And now, again, we're
asking ourselves,
as an organization, what
is the role of innovation.
How do we want it to be
both a cultural trait
and so that we have the hardcore
skill sets to life up ventures?
And so we're constantly
playing with that whole concept
of innovation, a critically
important part of who
we are as an organization.
And we know we have a long
ways to go, as you can see.
I was thinking
about that question,
the use of technology.
And one of the things that
just kills me is procurement.
For example, in a case like
this, what you always hear is,
there are these villages
in the middle of nowhere
who don't have access to
the basic services and goods
that they need.
And yet we know
that there are goods
that are not that far away.
How can we connect
the dots faster?
Weeks and weeks, sometimes,
in a place like this.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, to
even layer on top of that,
the WHO may have 20 trucks
and UNICEF has 1,000 tarps.
How do you both
coordinate the supply side
and match it to the demand
side real-time, effectively,
and the least amount of cost
and least amount of risk.
CRAIG REDMOND: That's just a nut
that we have to crack somehow.
AUDIENCE: Craig, I'd
be interested to hear
you talk a little bit about
how you made decisions
on how to deploy your resources
where there are a lot of places
that you could possibly go.
And how do you make the
decision about where to go?
And how do you make
the decision about when
it's time to close it down?
CRAIG REDMOND: That's
a great question.
As an organization,
we're very decentralized.
We have a distributed model so
that we have regional teams.
And our countries huddle
under those regional teams.
And basically, the big
decisions around what's
happening day to day are made
by those teams out there.
Those things don't come
to me and my team at all.
So that's that first layer
as a way that we operate.
We just believe people
closest to the action
have to be calling the shots.
That's not to say that we
don't have central resources
that we have to call upon.
We have an emergency
response team
that, when something happens,
we say, this one looks bad.
We're tracking it.
We follow the news just
like everybody does.
We reach into our
networks to make
sure we have all the
information we can get,
as fast as possible,
about what's
happening in the storm
that's about the crash
into the coast of Mexico.
In the hours before that,
we sent teams from Guatemala
and from Colombia in there to
make sure that they were there
and ready to go, just in
case that thing was horrible.
Thank god, in this
case, it wasn't.
But we looked at
it and thought, it
looks bad enough to
where we should probably
be pre-positioned there.
So we have a team
that does that.
Otherwise, to tell
you the truth,
it's more of an
art than a science.
We're watching it.
We're thinking, who could
we get there faster,
somebody from Europe or somebody
who's sitting in Zimbabwe?
And hopefully, we have
the teams and the skill
sets who are ready to go
and address that thing.
And we send those people
as fast as possible.
So a lot of
conversations happen.
Sometimes we don't have the
conversations fast enough.
And we ding ourselves and
we think, OK, we should
have done that another way.
But it's about moving resources
and really smart, capable
people around as
quickly as possible.
Shutting down-- shutting
down an operation
is oftentimes much
harder than starting one.
Because when you start
one, it's very clear,
you need to be there,
this thing happened.
And it's not always
an emergency.
We're not only an emergency
response organization.
Shutting one down is another--
several things happen.
Number one, what usually happens
when we shut one down is we
feel that there are skills and
capacities locally available
such that they
can do what we do.
Oftentimes, that's the case.
And sometimes we build those
institutions from the ground
up so that they can replace us.
We're not in the
long-term business
of being in a country
for 25 years, though we
have in some places,
like Afghanistan.
That's the main thing.
Oftentimes, unfortunately,
there are some places
where there is no funding.
Case in point would be Sudan.
We're there.
We're operating.
We need to be there.
Darfur is a horrible
situation still.
We're committed to being there.
And I'm telling you, it's
getting harder and harder
to be there, just because
the funding situation is such
that, probably, at
some point, we'll
have to make tough choices, shut
down something else in order
to stay operational there.
So I would say those
are the kinds of things
that go through our minds in
deciding what to shut down.
AUDIENCE: Question
is, what advice
do you have to others
considering disaster relief
work or volunteering positions.
And I guess I'd add
to that, specifically,
for someone who has
never been to Nepal,
would you recommend they go
there to do this kind of work?
MALE SPEAKER: I would
say that there are a lot
of opportunities in Nepal
for anyone who has been there
as well as people who haven't.
I think that the
diversity of experience,
skill sets, and perspective
that people can bring
is very valuable.
Especially from
within Google, we
had a team that
was very diverse.
I mean, Aswan, who probably
hasn't shared any of this,
he's a trained medical doctor
in addition to consulting,
in addition to
operations and business.
CRAIG REDMOND: You want a job?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so very
esteemed and skilled colleagues
as well as some of our
top engineers, operations.
So we had a real dream team
that was assembled together
to go to Nepal.
And I think we were
all able to play
very interesting and different
roles that, together, coalesced
very well.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
the critical success
factors, really, would be,
you have a passion to help,
you're open to the
idea that you may not
have 100% of your
modern conveniences,
and you really care
about learning.
Because it's very
easy to take the view
that you're coming in to do
something for somebody else,
but they're shaping you.
The problem is shaping
you in the solution
just as much as you're helping
to influence the problem.
So those are the
big three that I
would look at to
evaluate whether or not
you're a good fit.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
think, as was alluded to,
sometimes these
are not commitments
that just end at
the time when you're
on the plane to return back.
But there's follow-up
and additional work
that is something that
you can contribute
to even though you've
left a place, but also
very critical to seeing
that the implementation
and that the solution
really goes into practice.
AUDIENCE: Aswan,
I really liked how
you described your experience
as not donating your time
but investing it.
I'd love to hear from you
and Scott, maybe something
that you're doing
differently or thinking about
differently now that you're
back in the Bay Area.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll say that
on a recent trip to New York,
I had an opportunity to meet
with some of our open source
platform partners that
we were working with.
And so I had a chance to both do
this work as well as the Google
work on the side.
And then at another
conference a couple weeks ago,
I found a software
provider that was actually
offering their software
for free to non-profits.
And so we've seen
that, actually,
the situation as we had known
it on the ground in Nepal
has continued to evolve,
from increased connections
that we've made after the fact
and additional information
that we've learned.
So seeing that,
actually, there are
lots of opportunities to
remain engaged and follow up.
MALE SPEAKER: So I
think, for me, there's
probably two social
activities and then there's
one personal behavioral change.
I think the two
social activities
are elevating the visibility
of this type of work
for folks to recognize
that there is something
that they can do even if
their job seems very, very
distant from what could help.
Even if you start looking at
the professional landscape,
people are looking
for intersections
of very different content
areas and expertise.
Because a lot of
innovation actually
happens at the confluence
of two of those things.
So for me, elevating
visibility is one.
The second piece, I
would say, is also
advocacy in that,
through this experience,
I feel, now more
so than ever, it's
important not only to be part
of the immediate response,
but then also to have that
continuity to continue
to donate through recovery.
And I hadn't segregated
those two things
as part of a disaster, but
now I very much understand.
And to the point
that Craig just made,
the funding is running
out, because people
have started to lose interest.
But the need is still there.
On the personal front, I
have two young children.
And I'm trying to-- I
think there's always
been this push towards, OK,
they have all their needs met,
so let me focus them on
academics and so on and so
forth.
But the shaping experiences
with the children
that we met where they
put serving others
above their immediate
needs, I feel
like that's a mindset that
is more valuable for me
to inculcate into my
children than just, OK,
can you do your math.
Can you do your science?
Can you do your reading
and writing effectively?
So I know that's more a thematic
change that I'm trying to do.
But I feel like a
lot of these things
actually start pretty early.
And even if you haven't
done them early,
there's an opportunity
for you to do them
when you're older as well.
So for me, it's just exposure
for my children, for my family.
CRAIG REDMOND: Sure.
On behalf of Mercy Corps, I
want to thank you all again.
It's a wonderful
opportunity to be
able to stand here
with my friends
Aswan and Scott to talk about
our shared experience there.
As I said at the close
of my comments here,
I'm really proud of the
work that we did together.
And if you scan the
globe, even just briefly,
there are so many
opportunities for us
to do wonderful things together.
So I look forward to that.
And thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]